this is gonna be
um three stages
that's what these three things are on
the side they're quite easy to remember
but i've got eight steps you're like
eight steps eight
steps and i couldn't come up with a nice
acronym
um to put it so if you as i go through
this
i'm not even gonna bother trying to
pronounce that as i go through this
if you can try to come up with something
better than that
then um please be
yeah well that's what i mean like if you
can come up with a word okay
it sounds memorable to me but then the
problem is you remember that but you
don't even know how to spell the thing
that you just said which kind of
defeats the purpose of an actor
it's it's it's like it sounds obvious
okay
so i'm gonna go through the steps right
um there are eight steps by the way
because
i wanted to make them all quite detailed
so that when you get all these i know
exactly what to do
all right so here's where we begin the
first thing you want to do is analyze
the question
before you put pen to paper and actually
write down any variables or equations or
anything like that you just got to
understand what's going on
okay now the way that i do that
everyone's different
but i generally do two things first i'll
underline all the important parts in the
question
right because it's all verbal generally
speaking it's verbal though okay
so there's words there's phrases you're
like these are the important bits that
i'm gonna have to pay attention to
the second thing i'm gonna do where it
applies okay is i'm gonna draw it
so sort of a lion's share of maximum
problems are geometric in some way
okay we saw that yesterday with like the
a4 piece of paper now you can picture it
but it's so much better if you actually
have it drawn and you can label it and
say here's x here's 20 minus 2x and so
on and so forth
so that's what i do to just wrap my
brain around what is this question
getting out okay second thing you're
going to do is remember
the question just says try and maximize
this all that and
you know these different things can
change so in order to actually talk
about and form some
um mathematical statements you need to
assign
some pronouns
okay now anything that can vary
in the question right um the variables
anything that can vary can have a
pronumeral on it
right but you probably try to uh
minimize the number of pronouns you have
because if you have lots and lots later
on you're just gonna have to get rid of
more of them in fact we just want to get
sort of towards one or two right
so have as few principles as you can but
you'll have to say you must make this
statement
you have to say let the area be a let
the length of
the side length of the square that
you're going to cut out from the corners
of the
sheet let it be x you can't just start
talking about premium rules and not
introduce them and define what they are
okay so maybe you could even say instead
of just a sign you could say define them
because you actually have to say
it's this length or it's this amount of
time or whatever okay
i might put that there
gotta have that stamp before you start
talking about it okay
all right now once you've got your x's
or your y's or your ends
then you want to take these bits that
you underlined in the question
right the important details and you want
to form some equations out of it right
so for instance uh we formed equations
like x plus y equals 8
because those two numbers add up to
eight or equations like the volume is
x times 20 minus two and so on and so on
okay
so forcing equations uh but be careful
okay because uh in these two steps right
these are the two steps where
you want to know any restrictions that
come with
these kinds of equations and variables
so for instance when you're writing down
the pronoun rules you might immediately
see for instance
x must be greater than zero okay well x
must be less than
ten okay so you'll get some restrictions
when you write them down the first time
but you also might get some restrictions
based on what kind of equations you've
got right so for instance if you have
like a square root
you know somehow this this appears okay
you might have noted before in this step
that okay x has to be greater than zero
but once you write down this equation
once you form that that implies another
restriction mainly that x has to be
less than or equal to five okay so both
of these steps will give you some
restrictions
okay all right what does e stand for
e stands for eliminate any
unnecessary premium rules or variables
okay
eliminate unnecessary
pronunciation and we were doing this
before you know
we had x plus y equals eight that was a
nice way
to um form an equation off
what was in the question right but a
better way to do it is to
say well look i don't really need two
variables here i don't need two
pronunciations i can get them all in
terms of one and i think we did it in
terms of y
right okay so wherever we can get rid of
them
and really what we want to end up with
is just one
okay you want to get down to one right
you want the quantity that you want to
maximize or minimize you want it in
terms of one variable and one only
because that'll let you do the next step
which is
different differentiate
okay so the point of getting
just one pronumeral right uh i think we
had like d n on
n in terms of y right is so that you can
differentiate and find the turning
points okay
oh sorry i missed something earlier um
sorry
yes okay sorry i i missed something
which is up up here okay
not only should you note your
restrictions when you do these two but
when you've got your equations
you should also note discontinuities
they're quite rare to be honest
but you still have to watch out
sometimes you'll get them
okay and they'll come into play later on
all right now once you find your turning
points okay you find one at y equals
4 or y equals 3.9 or whatever it is okay
you've got to show that they're the kind
of turning point you're after
right so you're going to have to test
the turning points
okay use first derivative on either side
use the second derivative whatever
method you like
you've got to show that it's a maximum
or it's a minimum or whatever it is that
you're after
okay
okay once you've done that okay you've
gotta then think about all the different
kinds of ways that
this might be the minimum they're after
or it might not be
okay so you're going to need to e4
evaluate
now what are you going to evaluate
number one you're going to evaluate
where that turning point is okay so
testing the turning point means what
kind of turning point
is it evaluating the turning point means
okay take that value y equals four
and sub it into your original equation
right and see what number you get out at
the end
okay but don't just evaluate the turning
points you've also got to evaluate
the end points or if you like the
boundary values okay
and then you're going to be able to
compare them and see well
which one is the true maximum minimum
that i'm after
okay now by the way you might um you
might put this together in a table
because it'll just make it easier and
clearer for you when you're trying to
make a comparison
all right lastly when you've got all
that out of the way you just have to
finish things off
okay so you want to provide
justification
you want to justify why for instance
your relative minimum
is the absolute minimum that's what we
were doing yesterday okay
and then you want to give your final
answer
in the form of a sentence which directly
answers the question that was posed to
you
right what is the maximum volume the
maximum volume is
and this is where you would probably
include your um units and that kind of
thing centimeters cubed or whatever
because really strictly speaking when
you differentiate something a derivative
doesn't have units attached to it
um you bring the units in at the end all
right so i said there's my
eight steps and you can sort of group
them together into
um three stages okay this first bit here
we're really actually constructing the
question that we're trying to solve
okay you're putting everything together
you're setting it up you get making sure
everything's in the right
position before you actually begin to go
through problem solving
this step in here this is the calculus
step right
okay this is where you bring in all of
your knowledge of stationary points and
and so on and then lastly just conclude
don't get a turning point and then just
pack up and go home okay you've actually
got to finish things off and
tie it all up in a neat bow so if you
want you can call this the three c's
of maximum problem solving that was my
attempt my rather lame attempt to try
and make this a little memorable
like i said please come up with
something better than
than uh i'm not gonna try it
okay that would be really good um but
that's how i want you to approach all
the questions that you've got in um